>> Laura: WE WILL BRING YOU
THE LATEST IN JUST MOMENTS
FROM PENNSYLVANIA.
FIRST, PRESIDENT TRUMP
FAMOUSLY DID NOT VISIT
CALIFORNIA IN HIS FIRST YEAR
AS PRESIDENT.
WITH THE SANCTUARY POLICIES
AND ITS HOSTILE FAR LEFT
LEADERS, WHO COULD BLAME
THEM?
WELL, MR. TRUMP FINALLY HAD
A VALID REASON TO GO TO THE
GOLDEN STATE TODAY WHERE HE
TOOK A LOOK AT THE
PROTOTYPES OF HIS BORDER
WALL IN SAN DIEGO.
AND HE EXPLAINED WHY THE
WALL IS ESSENTIAL.
>> IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FENCE AND IT'S A VERY
POWERFUL FENCE, NOT DOING
THE TRICK, BECAUSE THEY CUT
HOLES IN IT.
AND THEN THEY ARE PATCHING
HOLES ALL THE TIME.
I'M JUST LOOKING.
HAVE YOU HUNDREDS OF HOLES
CUT IN AND PATCHED.
SO THE FENCE IS NOT STRONG
ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT IDEA.
BUT, FOR THOSE PEOPLE, IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A WALL
SYSTEM, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE A COUNTRY.
>> Laura: IS HE BACK ON THE
CONSTRUCTION SITE TODAY.
I LOVED IT JOINING US NOW
FOR REACTION IS THE CEO WHO
SUBMITTED ONE OF THOSE
PROTOTYPES, FISHER SAND AND
GRAVEL CEO TOMMY FISHER
JOINS US FROM PHOENIX.
OKAY, FISHER SAND AND
GRAVEL.
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR, I DON'T KNOW,
SINCE 1952.
IT'S A FAMILY RUN COMPANY.
AND WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO HAVE
THE PRESIDENT CHECK OUT THE
PROTOTYPE TODAY?
>> IT WAS A GREAT HONOR FOR
MYSELF AND ALL THE EMPLOYEES
AND HOPEFULLY MY DAD LOOKING
DOWN FROM HEAVEN TO SEE
WHERE WE HAVE COME TO.
TO HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE TO THE PRESIDENT
AND ALL THE PEOPLE OF
AMERICA WHAT WE ARE CAPABLE
OF BUILDING, IT WAS JUST A
GREAT HONOR.
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOUR COMMITMENT AND
DETERMINATION TO KEEP BORDER
SECURITY FRONT AND CENTER
WITH ALL YOUR VIEWERS AS
WELL, LAURA.
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY.
I WANT TO PLAY A SOUND BITE.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT, YOU
KNOW, HE WAS LOOKING AT ALL
THE DIFFERENT PRIPS.
HE MADE LIKE A RUNNING
COMMENTARY THROUGHOUT.
THIS IS A PART OF IT LET'S
WATCH.
>> WE ARE LOOKING VERY MUCH
AT THE WALL WITH SOME SEE
THROUGH CAPABILITY ON THE
OTHER SIDE AND SOLID
CONCRETE ON TOP OR STEEL AND
CONCRETE ON TOP.
THE ROUND PIECE THAT YOU SEE
UP HERE OR SEE MORE CLEARLY
BACK THERE, THE LARGER IT
IS, THE BETTER IT IS BECAUSE
IT'S VERY HARD TO GET OVER
THE TOP.
IT'S REALLY DETERRENT FROM
GETTING OVER THE TOP.
WHO WOULD THINK?
BUS,
BUT,
BUT GETTING OVER THE TOP IS
EASY.
THESE ARE LIKE PROFESSIONAL
MOUNTAIN CLIMBERS.
THEY ARE INCREDIBLE
CLIMBERS.
THEY CAN'T CLIMB SOME OF
THESE WALLS.
SOME OF THEM THEY CAN.
THOSE ARE THE WALLS WE ARE
NOT USING.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, TOMMY,
WHICH WALL WAS HE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE WERE WATCHING SOUND BITE
AFTER SOUND BITE TODAY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AGAINST
THIS WALL WHO ARE SAYING I
CAN'T GET OVER.
THIS I HAVE GOTTEN OVER
OTHER STRUCTURES BEFORE.
THERE IS NO WALL THEY CAN
MAKE TALL ENOUGH FOR ME NOT
TO GET OVER BECAUSE I'M
DETERMINED TO GET BACK IN
THE UNITED STATES WHERE CAN
I MAKE SOME MONEY OR SEE MY
FAMILY.
SO, WHAT MAKES YOUR WALL
IMPENETRABLE FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO REALLY WANT TO CLIMB IT.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
LAURA, OUR WALL IS SOLID
CONCRETE, IF YOU ARE SEE
THROUGH, YOU ARE BASICALLY A
FENCE OR CUT LIKE PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER WITH THE STEEL.
AND STEEL HAS ITS PURPOSE
OUT ON THE BORDER.
BUT BASICALLY ENCASED IN OUR
CONCRETE.
THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE IS WE
TOOK VISION VERY SERIOUS
WHEN WE PUT OUR PROPOSAL
TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHY OUR WALL IS
STRONG ENOUGH TO BE
BACKFILLED THEY HAVE
360-DEGREE PANORAMIC TOP
VIEW DOWN SO THEY HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE.
HOPEFULLY THE PRESIDENT WILL
GET TO SEE THAT WITH SOME OF
THE OTHER PICTURES.
THE DINNERS IS WE CAN BUILD
THROUGH THE MOUNTAINS AS
WELL.
WE HAVE A PRODUCT THAT LASTS
150 YEARS.
IT BROKE MY HEART TODAY TO
SEE THE PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT
FIXING A WALL THAT'S BEEN
OUT THERE THAT'S A REMNANT
WALL OR SOMETHING AND SOME
OF THAT WALL HAS ONLY BEEN
OUT THERE, THE FENCE I WANT
TO SAY, THE STEEL FENCE 10
YEARS UP TO 20-SOME YEARS
AND THEY'RE REPLACING.
OUR YEAR HAS 150 YEAR LIFE
SPAN.
THE BIG DIFFERENCE WITH OURS
IS, WE ARE BUILDING ACCESS
ROADS FOR THE AGENTS.
SO YOU ARE NOT EVEN GETTING
CLOSE TO OUR WALL.
OUR WALL HAS A ROAD IN
FRONT, A ROAD BEHIND.
IT HAS SUCH A SUPERIOR
ADVANTAGE.
THAT'S WHY WE WERE ABLE TO
SECURE THE BOND GAVE ANYMORE
INIAN FOR 10.77 BILLION.
LIKE I TALKED TO YOU ON ROOT
SHOW TO BUILD 700 MILES.
I ALSO PLACED
274-MILLION-DOLLAR BAND WITH
LAND THAT I JUST PURCHASED
IN CALIFORNIA TO BUILD THE
FIRST 15 MILES IN THE MOST
RUGGED MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN
TO PROVE TO THE PRESIDENT AS
WELL AS EVERY AMERICAN, IF
YOU TONIGHT HAVE A COMPLETE
BORDER PROTECTION SYSTEM,
YOU DO NOT HAVE SECURITY.
AND LIKE YOU SAID EARLIER, I
TAKE WITH GREAT RESPECT THE
PRESIDENT WILL, IF HE ALLOWS
US TO PLAY OUR TEAM FISHER
INDUSTRIES TO PLAY, I
GUARANTEE YOU NO DIFFERENT
THAN TOM BRADY, ONCE WE GET
IN WE NEVER COME OUT.
IF WE DON'T PERFORM, THE
PRESIDENT CAN FIRE US.
THAT'S HOW COMFORTABLE AND
CONFIDENT I AM IS WHEN WE
REALLY OFFER.
>> Laura: I LOVE IT.
NOT TAKING SIDES WHICH
PROTOTYPES IS BEST THIS IS
WHY YOU ARE A GOOD
BUSINESSMAN.
HOW MANY JOBS ARE WE TALKING
AND REALLY QUICK WHAT TYPES
OF JOBS ARE THESE GOOD
PAYING JOBS?
ONLY AMERICAN PRODUCTS AND
ONLY AMERICANS WORKERS,
RIGHT.
>> ALL-AMERICAN WITH
ALL-AMERICAN GRIT.
WE PROBABLY IF WE DID THE
BIG PROJECT, THE 700 MILES
YOU ARE TALKING THOUSANDS OF
JOBS WITH US AND OUR
PARTNERS.
THE SMALLER JOB, PROBABLY
1,000 JOBS.
BUT HERE'S THE BIG
DIFFERENCES.
OUR PRODUCT AND OUR PATENT
PENDING SYSTEM DOES NOT NEED
CRANES.
WHEN WE GO INTO THE
MOUNTAINS, LAURA IN 30
MINUTES YOU COULD BE RUNNING
ONE OF OUR ESCALATORS AND
PULL BACK WALL FORMS YOU
WOULD SEE 30 FEET OF PERFECT
WALL BUILT.
>> Laura: TOMMY FISHER.
FISHER SAND AND GRAVEL.